la chronique de l'innovation avec
Valérie oribo donc Valérie nous allons
parler ce soir donc de ce cluster vous
nous le disiez en présentation
d'émission oui absolument alors je
reprécise un cluster et non une
pépinière d'entreprise car il y a une
petite nuance hein la pépinière
d'entreprise est beaucoup plus
impersonnelle il y a moins de synergie
entre les entreprises pour en parler
Gérard D bonsoir président et fondateur
de genaris Group qui dirige donc ce
cluster am et et Hervé fouard bonsoir
président de l'une des PMI ver texi qui
a rejoint donc ce cLOSTER donc Gérard D
vous avez créé ce cLOSTER en février
2011 il s'agit bien d'un cLOSTER nom
d'une pépinaire d'entreprise pouvez-vous
nous nous rappeler la la différence
entre les deux oui ben écoutez j'ai ma
définition donc globalement donc j'ai
souhaité donc essayer de faire
bénéficier des PME françaises des PME
franiliennes d'idé qui existe déjà dans
d'autres pays notamment aux USA qui est
de dire bon d'essayer de trouver un mode
économique un mode donc de d'échange un
mode de complémentarité pour que les
sociétés se consacrent sur leur
développement se consacrent sur les sur
le développement de leur entreprise le
recrutement l'encadrement et qu'on
puisse mutualiser des coûts qui sont des
installations la nécessité de d'avoir
accès à des réseaux Internet nécessité
d'avoir donc des des des des relations
avec les directions financières les
relation financièr des grands groupes
donc tous ces aspects là donc sont des
aspects qui sont des contraintes pour
les dirigeants de PME de petite PME et
donc voilà donc c'est cette synergie là
c'est ce service là que je propose donc
aux entités qui sont venu nous rejoindre
donc et et qui aujourd'hui on peut le
reconnaître donc on enregistré et toutes
ces ces PME PMI donc collabore travaill
ensemble tout à fait et sont
complémentaires oui bah c'est-à-dire que
elle
profite des synergies des synergies
commerciales elle profite donc des
visites des différents clients elle
profite donc des compétences qui existe
dans les autres PME c'est le cas d'Hervé
fouard pour sa société vertexi qui
profite du fait qu'il y a dans le dans
le cluster un bureau d'étude et donc qui
qui vient éventuellement donner des une
assistance dans certaines caillé des
charges dans certaines demande de ses
clients c'est le cas donc à partir de
très récemment où dans donc Hervé a eu
besoin donc de de de pouvoir donc
récupérer des fichiers sur des petites
pièces et c'est une autre société qui
qui a qui a un savoir-faire dans la
tomographie qui va lui fournir les
éléments donc justement dans quel
domaine d'intervention vous travaillez
alors nous sommes sur le marché sur le
secteur de l'innovation industrielle
donc bien évidemment nous intervenons
pour les donc les grands groupes les
grands groupes industriels de
l'automobile bien évidemment avec une
une grosse importance dans l'automobile
puisque nous sommes sur un plateau euh
prier département en
terut donc nous avons accès à des à des
au constructeurs n PSA entre autres euh
nous intervenons sur d'autres secteurs
d'activité donc sur le marché militaire
qui nous a donc confié un certain nombre
de projets nous intervenons sur le
marché aéronautique et ça c'est innovant
justement je vous interromps mais
travailler sur le domaine de
l'automobile dans le cadre d'un cluster
c'est innovant ça se fait déjà ça c'est
déjà fait ou c'est pres c'estd que de
cette manière-là je pense que donc nous
sommes nous sommes précurseurs de cette
manière-là donc euh il faut bien
comprendre que on va très loin parce
qu'on est capable de partager des
ressources de calcul des ressources de
puissance d'ordinateur on partage on
partage quand même des des ressources
vertexi donc partie calcul donc a des
calculateurs à des puissances de calcul
et s'appuie sur les puissances de calcul
aussi du groupe générri et d'autres
entités pour pouvoir avoir encore plus
de puissance on va quand même assez loin
dans la la démarge de ces entreprises
partagent aussi vos vos connaissances et
votre parcours puisque vous aviez jadis
un bureau d'Ét
et vous avez vousmême des des contacts
depuis longtemps avec les les grands
groupes aujourd'hui vous pouvez
justement faire bénéficier de ces
contacts à ces PME qui rejoent
rejoignent ce cluster tout à fait c'est
le cas au quotidien mais je suis pe-être
mal placé pour en parler vous faites
référence à ces activités présentez-nous
déjà votre entreprise vertexi vous
travaillez sur quoi alors nous on est
donc une société d'ingénierie
industrielle spécialisé en ce qu'on
appelle en calcul donc on fait du
calcul de structure ou du calcul de
fluide alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu' on dimensionne virtuellement
des des prototypes on développe
principalement bah comme on l'a dit he
pour le milieu automobile par exemple on
a
participé pour Renault à l'élaboration
du des systèmes de dégivrage de
ventilation notamment pour la nouvelle
Clio ou pour Zoe et ce qu'on fait bah
avant qu'effectivement que toute
maquette existe physique en fait on se
place dans l'univers virtuel on fait des
calculs à ce niveau-là on représente en
3D on regarde on simule un petit peu le
le comportement futur du matériel et on
voit comment l'intégrer dans bah là par
exemple dans dans une automobile VO et
vous pour vous intégrer un cluster
c'était vraiment quelque chose de de
plus est-ce que c'est rassurant ent doué
FR en fait voilà les derniers en rien
qu'avc le cluster rien qu'avec le
cluster ah oui tout à fait c'était
vraiment très performant donc c'est sûr
que il y a eu beaucoup de synergie et
c'est vraiment enfin je suis même
premier surpris de l'efficacité je vous
vois ravis quand vous ça non mais c'est
vrai les chiffres parlent les les
chiffres parlent c'est vrai c'était
vraiment on en espérait pas de temps
surtout que le contexte automobile n'est
pas le plus peut-être favorable en ce
moment surtout dans milieu automobile
donc et en plus malgré tout ça marche et
voilà et et en plus l'avantage c'est que
on avant on était vraiment très focalisé
dans le milieu automobile et maintenant
c'est diversifié dans d'autres secteurs
donc l'aéronautique l'énergie et
l'environnement donc donc ça nous a
effectivementur de métier reste
l'automobile oui mais de moins en moins
ENF c'est dire que en fait le métier du
calcul on va dire c'est enfin
l'initiateur c'est un petit peu
l'automobile c'est eux qui avait au
départ les budgets pour parce que ça
Nite quand même une puissance de calcul
assez important donc il y a des quand
même des coûts hein donc c'est eux qui
ont initié en fait surtout dans
l'automobile le métier du du calcul et
après maintenant bah on l'adopte pour
d'autres d'autres secteurs industrielle
ça alors nous avons rencontré pas mal de
de de PME qui nous ont dit au sein du
cluster recruter euh être en recherche
d'ingénieurs de cableurs de de toutes
sortes de de de professions euh c'est
votre cas aussi dans ce cluster alors
vous c'est les témoignag que vous avez
recill ce qui peut être surprenant ce
moment oui tout à fait recherches Activ
de collaborateurs sur à peu près toutes
les structure du cluster son en
recherche de collaborateur donc ça c'est
clair c'est évident mais ça fait partie
effectivement des ça veut dire qu'il B
de gens formés aussi pour justement
intégrer vos entreprises oui bah c'estàd
que bon c'est c'est c'est de pouvoir
avoir accès à ces personnes là c'est de
se faire connaître pour une PME c'est
aussi difficile donc il faut il faut
avoir des ressources il faut avoir des
structures qui s'en occupent donc dans
le CAD de Hervé bah c'est Hervé qui fait
à la fois la gestion qui fait à la fois
le développement qui aussi gère les
projets il faut savoir que c'est
l'univers de du chef d'entreprise d'une
société qui a 10 personnes 5 personnes
c'est c'est ça l'univers donc alors
est-ce que vous avez eu des aides de la
part de de des des villes de de du
département pour pour mettre en place ce
cluster non je suis je dois avouer quand
même que ça fait partie de mes de mes
scrupulle de mes insatisfactions de pas
avoir su convaincre les uns les autres
bon après tout euh je j'ai vite perçu
que mon projet était difficile à
comprendre difficile à à expliquer on
m'a confondu avec un avec sur un projet
immobilier on m'a dit qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce cette ce type de
machinile Act de créer une entreprise
non pas non je pense pas je peux pas
dire ça le midf tirait la sonnette
d'alarme cette cette semaine nêtes pas
convaincu oui non non je pense pas qu'il
soit difficile pas plus difficile
qu'avant de créer une entreprise c'est
difficile d'avoir accès à des a c'est
difficile d'avoir mais simplement quand
on crée une entreprise on pense pas aux
a on pense aux marché c'est le marché
qui rémunè les entreprises c'est pas les
aides c'est pas les subventions c'est
pas bon il se trouve que il y a un
certain nombre d'acteurs autour de nous
dans les collec collectivités locales
que ces acteurs souhaitent participer
mais aujourd'hui il y a pas d'efficacité
et je regrette cette
efficacité parce qu'elle est criante je
dire aujourd'hui moi je pensais j'étais
parti avec des principes de dire bah
écoutez je j'aurais peut-être de l'aide
des collectivités locales pour
identifier les PME je n'ai pas pas eu
d'aide je pensais avoir des difficultés
avec les avec les chef avec les clients
pour dire je vais avoir des objections
qu'est-ce qui va se passer F finement ça
n'a pas marché comme c'était prévu mais
ça fonctionne mais voilà donc bon et
finalement aujourd'hui vous êtes en
recherche de de PME des PMI qui qui
pourrai vous vous rejoindre encore des
mètres carrés de bureau disponible voà
absolument 150 m Carr de bureau
disponibles tout à fait 150 car 150 m
car de bureau disponible et 600 m Carr
d'activité dispon disponible puisqu'il y
a aussi à la fois donc des mètres carrés
de bureau hightech et aussi de
l'activité puisque donc les entreprises
certaines sont à la fois donc on besoin
donc de bureaux et d'activités pour
pouvoir réaliser leurs prestation donc
bien évidemment je si on a imaginer
parce que donc les nouveau rousentrants
sont coopté par ceux qui existent déjà
parce qu' ne doit pas y avoir de
concurrence mais de complémentarité au
sein du cluster pas de conflit d'intérêt
au sein du cluster donc cé important et
c'est une formule qui semble plutôt
marcher merci d'être venu nous est V
présenter ce cluster nouveau cluster
dans les evelines merci Valérie on vous
retrouve mardi prochain sur ce plateau
pour une autre chronique à suivre dans
ce 78 un tout autre sujet le témoignage
de Sergey Babinet un avocat de 24 ans il
se bat pour la défense des droits
humains en tchenie Amnesy internationale
l' invité à témoigné en France il était
dans les ivelines aujourd'hui la fête de
la science se poursuit des animations se
déroulent un peu partout comme ce speed
meeting organisé dans un centre
commercial
reportage c'est plutôt l'hélium liquide
qui va être dans cette température là et
encore
drôle de discussion dans un centre
commercial entre scientifique passionnés
et le public l'espace Saint-Quentin à
montigi accueillait la Fête de la
Science les expériences se veulent
ludiques ici par exemple on parle du
froid et de la température glace de
carbone et azote liquide des éléments à
-
180° c'est ici qu'on peut se permettre
de désacraliser des choses de faire
sortir des choses qui sont dangereuse à
peu rentre dans l'esprit dans
l'imaginaire collectif et donc de
réussir à désacraliser des points pour
faire changer une image faire évoluer
une image et permettre aux gens de se
rapprocher de quelque chose et de se
dire bah c'est pas parce que j'étais nul
en science et que j'étais bloqué sur les
Tabl de multiplication en CP que je suis
forcément un idiot fini c'est pas très
loin
de le temps de le
dire c'est très intéressant ça permet
d'aider les gens à à se diriger vers des
vers la science alors que ça peut
paraître assez difficile et spécifique
je trouve ça pas mal quoi c'est ça
permet gens de plus s'orienter vers des
des filières s parce que ben nous on a
plutôt des a prioris dessus justement
Ivan sache est chercheur en pathologie
végétale il est venu aussi à la
rencontre du public une nécessité selon
ce scientifique de linra qui soulligne
que ces travaux sont financés par des
fonds publics les jeunes sont attirés
par la science mais il faut arriver à le
expliquer ce que c'est et surtout la
gamme des métiers qui est qui est très
très large il y a pas des chercheurs
avec des blouses d'ailleurs j'en ai pas
il y a des métiers techniques il y a des
informaticiens il y a tout une gamme de
métiers le gros moi le gros plaisir que
j'ai dans ce métier c'est tout ces
personnes travaillent ensemble on fait
pas de la science tout seul je suis
devenu chercheur parce que j'ai
rencontré des chercheurs on pris le
tempsexquer ce qu'il fais pourquoi il le
fais je suis rentré dans le métier comme
ça